[Musique]
bonsoir à this conseillère municipal de
Poissy délégué au bien-être animal alors
après les chiens après le lapin vous
étiez venu aussi avec un lapin ce soir
c'est avec un cochon d'inde que vous
êtes venu pour nous parler justement de
cet animal comment s'en occuper vous
allez nous donner tous vos bons conseils
déjà une petite fiche d'identité qui qui
est-il oui alors c'est Roméo donc qui
est qui a un petit cochon d'Inde qui
n'est ni un cochon est né un indien en
fait c'est Christophe Colomb qui croyait
être en Inde et avec les navigateurs
comme le cochon d'inde et Queen et ben
ils ont surnommé le cochon d'inde voilà
j'ai offert un petit descriptif que de
nos cochons d'Inde qui sont très adoptés
par les familles françaises on les
appelle d'ailleurs les NAC ce sont les
nouveaux animaux de compagnie donc c'est
des animaux je parle doucement parce que
c'est des animaux qui sont vraiment très
craintifs ils ont donc au niveau de la
vision il voit en noir et blanc au
niveau niveau des incisives donc leurs
incisives elles le poussent constamment
et puis ils ont un odorat qui est très
développé ils vont reconnaître leur
congénère à l'odeur de leur urine et ils
aiment vivre par deux donc dès que vous
avez un cochon d'inde c'est mieux de les
avoir par deux ils vont ils vivront plus
longtemps quel âge a-t-il Il a 2 ans et
demi Roméo deux ans et demi et vous nous
disiez au niveau du caractère le cochon
d'inde est en général craintif oui alors
il a un sacré caractère pas vrai qu'on
Romeo c'est un ils sont craintifs en
fait ils ont un caractère qui est un peu
donnant-donnant donc ils aiment beaucoup
l'attention les caresses et si vous ne
lui donnez pas beaucoup d'attention il
va vous donner des coups de pâte avec
ses pattes arrières également des jets
d'urine et par contre à l'inverse donc
c'est un animal qui est très intelligent
si vous lui rendez bien il va vous le
rendre en couinant il va vous le rendre
vraiment avec des câlins et puis donc
c'est un très bon communicant il aime
beaucoup la vie en groupe il est au
niveau donc au niveau du contact avec
génère ça va être le contact buccal ils
vont même se renifler le train arrière
les uns les autres c'est pour ça chaque
émission je le dis attention à l'obésité
de votre animal ça va couper le lien
social avec les autres
et du coup un animal fragile on
l'imagine un animal très fragile comme
il est petit de taille sa queue me met
toute petite il y a que cet OS il faut
faire attention l'eau froide pour pas
qu'il n'ait la diarrhée et puis à son
alimentation donc faut veiller à ce
qu'il est beaucoup de fruits de légumes
c'est un bon modèle pour les maris et
les enfants et il faut surtout qu'il ait
beaucoup de foin pour sa digestion
pour justement entretenir Romeo pour
prendre soin de lui et puis au niveau
cardiaque comme il est très craintif il
faut éviter la crise cardiaque qu'il ait
une cachette au niveau de son habitat où
il pourra se réfugier comment s'en
occupe très concrètement alors
commençons à avoir une grande cage
beaucoup communiquer avec lui chaque
fois que vous passez dans sa cage lui
donner des belles paroles donc ce qui
est bien c'est que ça apprendra aussi
aux enfants de s'habituer à être
bienveillant envers les autres mais vous
le disiez alors en général c'est mieux
quand ils sont deux c'est pas un animal
solitaire vaut mieux qu'il y a quelqu'un
avec lui c'est ça c'est un animal il
vaut mieux et qu'il ait quelqu'un avec
lui qui soit entouré c'est le seul
animal d'ailleurs qui peut vivre avec 5
à 10 congénères donc veillez bien le
stériliser et puis surtout jamais de mal
dans une même cage avec une femelle là
c'est le jet d'urine assuré dans votre
habitation est-ce qu'on peut avoir
d'autres animaux de compagnie alors au
niveau un lapin oui par contre avec le
chien et chat ça fera mauvais de ménage
Romeo lui il est à l'étage et le chien
est en bas la durée de vie d'un cochon
d'inde alors la durée de vie ça varie en
fait en fonction de son habitat entre 4
ans à 8 ans et puis en fonction de bah
comment vous allez le considérer dans la
famille donc et puis surtout veiller à
sa dentition l'occlusion buccale est
très très
visiblement on pose beaucoup de
questions dans l'oreillette on est
intéressé par le cochon d'inde est-ce
qu'on peut le mettre dans son jardin le
cochon d'inde est-ce qu'on peut le
sortir de sa cage ou c'est pas
recommandé alors il peut sortir de sa
cage puisqu'il vit en famille en plus il
vit aux mêmes horaires que vous en
journée donc oui oui tant qu'il y a pas
dedans j'ai et il faut l'habituer en
fait au lieu et il sort rarement le
cochon d'inde j'avais encore deux
questions est-ce que c'est un compagnon
idéal pour les enfants oui très idéal
pour les enfants parce qu'il est très
malléable alors les enfants surtout
attention quand vous le manipulez à ne
pas faire tomber le cochon d'inde et
puis c'est un animal donc qui aime
beaucoup l'attention donc ça c'est bien
pour pour les enfants et peut-être faire
des statistiques voir les gens qui ont
des cochons d'inde ils sont peut-être
tourner vers les autres peut-être dans
le médical ça j'aimerais bien faire une
petite cycle là dessus
l'adoption commence à se passe pour le
cochon d'inde alors en animalerie au
niveau des associations
où il y a beaucoup de naissances Roméo
lui par exemple il a été pris un
animalerie et un coup de foudre avec
Héloïse et Roméo au vu de sa jolie
houpette et puis Roméo lui a un mélomane
ou il adore la musique puisque Éloïse en
fait est une grande danseuse elle a
obtenu un prix elle a eu le 9e prix
Nijinski du Concours International de
Danse donc voilà Roméo je pense qu'il va
vite très longtemps merci beaucoup à
Athis pour tous ces bons conseils sur le
cochon d'inde merci à Roméo qui a été
très calme très sage il couine un tout
petit peu juste avant le début mais il
sait il s'est calmé le caresser pour
éviter les gîtes d'urine sur moi autour
de la table vous avez des cochons d'inde
vous en avez déjà eu non non voilà vous
en avez eu deux bon voilà en tout cas
tous les bons conseils merci beaucoup à
this barré vous vous revenez nous parler
de quoi la prochaine fois de qui attend
des moutons la semaine prochaine c'est
la période d'accord bon on vous retrouve
en tout cas la semaine prochaine merci
beaucoup pour tout ces bons conseils